so how did you end it with that guy
I'll tell you in a second
Selena Gomez's Nana tries to get all the
tea on her recent breakup oh my goodness
yeah cell who turns the big 3-0 Friday
shared the candid moment on Tick Tock
she films a makeup tutorial with her
beauty products and as she's applying
lip liner Nana strikes and asks the
personal question
so how did you end it with that guy
yeah cells clearly taken by surprise
I'll tell you in a second
the actresses fitting caption I have no
words the other big question here who is
the mystery guy Selena recently broke up
with do you know what else feel like
there's still a couple of loose ends
we'll be on the lookout for any clues on
that front but for now a source tells
E.T as Selena enters this new decade in
her life she isn't dating anyone
specific right now quote she is more
open to love but she is also very much
focused on herself and her work right
now she's in a very healthy place she is
feeling fantastic and very mentally
physically and emotionally healthy it's
been good single or taken one thing's
for sure Selena doesn't mind talking or
poking fun at her relationship status on
social media I'm very honest though in
general take these for example no I'm
fine I'm totally fine being single it's
a real thing it's fine last time I was
single I was 24 and the dating pool
at men I mean I'm just really trying to
holler at you forever now let me for
what you
holla at me for what I mean
um
but it's not just social media sells
also not afraid to talk love on live TV
one reason I'm really excited to host
SNL is because I'm single and
and I've heard that SNL is a great place
to find Romance
since I don't really want to try the
dating apps I just want to put it out in
the universe that I'm manifesting love
and I would like to say that I'm looking
for my soulmate but at this point I will
take anyone but come on this is Selena
Gomez we're talking about and this queen
isn't gonna take just anyone our source
says she wants someone who's trustworthy
respectful and honest with themselves
and others real supportive accepting
nice thoughtful funny and someone that's
not in it for the fame or attention I'm
ready to do it you know I'm ready to go
to the next level just one thing don't
expect her only murders in the building
co-stars Steve Martin and Martin Short
to play Cupid so they tried to set you
up with anybody no
no just just me you're protective we're
very protective over but but you know
most of the people we know are dead we
don't know anyone under 50. so it's not
like uh say I want you to meet Selena
[Music]